LIVE FROM NEW YORK AND SATURDAY.
ALL RIGHT SUCKER, GREAT SHOW AS
ALWAYS.
WELCOME TO USE "HANNITY" BARELY
BEGINS BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A
FOX NEWS ALERT.
WE ARE NOW TRACKING MAJOR
BREAKING STORIES INCLUDING A
BOMBSHELL DEVELOPING FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
FOX NEWS NOW REPORTING THAT THE
BARR INVESTIGATION INTO THE
ORIGINS OF THE RUSSIA WISH HON
IS EXPANDING.
FOX'S REPORTING IT IS OUR
CHEMICAL, MR. JEROME HAS
EXPANDED HIS INVESTIGATION AND
IS ADDING AGENCY RESOURCES, ONE
OF THE MULTIPLE ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS.
THE TIME I KNOW HAS GROWN FROM
THE BEGINNING OF THE PROBE
THROUGH THE ELECTION AND NOW
INCLUDES A POSTELECTION TIMELINE
THROUGH THE SPRING OF 2017 UP
UNTIL WHEN ROBERT MUELLER WAS
NAMED THE SPECIAL COUNSEL.
AS WE HAVE ARE SUPPORTED ON THE
SHOW, JEROME AND BARR HAVE
SPOKEN WITH MULTIPLE OFFICIALS
FROM THE U.K., AUSTRIA, EVEN
TRAVELED TO ITALY ALL IN AN
EFFORT TO DETERMINE THE MOST
POWERFUL IN TOOLS OF
INTELLIGENCE WERE USED
AGAINST OUR OWN CITIZENS.
OF COURSE TO CIRCUMVENT AMERICAN
LAWS AND THAT CONSTITUTIONAL
PROTECTION PAID BY THE WAY, THAT
PROTECTION PAID BY THE WAY, THAW
PROTECTION PAID BY THE WAY, THAU
PROTECTION PAID BY THE WAY, THAD
PROTECTION PAID BY THE WAY, THAB
PROTECTION PAID BY THE WAY, THAE
LIKE FISA ABUSE, PREMEDITATED
THE ROD, ONE OF THE SADDEST
THINGS FROM MY SOURCES TONIGHT,
THEY ARE WORRIED ABOUT IF THEY
WILL GET A CONVICTION IN D.C.
THAT SHOULDN'T MATTER.
THE LAW IS THE LAW.
WAS IT VERIFIED OR NOT VERIFIED?
WE WILL HAVE ANSWERS TO A LOT OF
THESE QUESTIONS COMING.
DID OFFICIALS CIRCUMVENT U.S.
LAW OUTSOURCED SURVEILLANCE AND
THE OTHER SENSE ON AMERICANS TO
ALLIED'S BY THE AGENCIES?
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU DO THIS FOR
US AND IN THIS WAY WE ARE
INNOCENT.
THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN, WHERE THEY
TARGETED BY OUR OWN GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES TO BOLSTER
HILLARY CLINTON AND HURT
DONALD TRUMP?
WHY WAS MUELLER APPOINTED IN THE
FIRST PLACE?
ACCORDING TO ANOTHER FOX SPORTS
TONIGHT, MUELLER WAS IN FACT
PURSUING THE ACTING FBI DIRECTOR
WHEN HE WAS PURSUING
DONALD TRUMP IN 2016.
HE DIDN'T GET THAT POSITION AND
JUST A SHORT TIME LATER HE WAS
INVESTIGATING THE PRESIDENT WHO
PASSED HIM OVER FOR A JOB.
THAT WOULD RAISE SERIOUS
CONFLICT OF INTEREST CONCERNS
NOT TO MENTION CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THE MAN THAT
TRUMP FIRED, MR. SUPER PATRIOT,
JIM COMEY.
BY THE WAY, THE HOROWITZ
INVESTIGATION UNCOVER ABOUT ALL
OF THIS AND MANY OTHERS WHO
WILLFULLY COMMITTED FRAUD
AGAINST THE FISA COURT?
IMAGINE IF ANY OF YOU COULD
COMMITTED A PREMEDITATED FRONT
OF COURT.
YOU SIGNED A DOCUMENT IN AN
APPLICATION FOR A WARRANT, TAKE
AWAY THE RIGHTS OF AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN, YOU CAN SPY ON THE
CAMPAIGN, AND HIS LATER
TRANSITION TEAM AND THEN LATER
THAT THE PRESIDENCY.
LET'S PLAY THIS GAME AT HOME.
DO YOU THINK YOU WOULD GET AWAY
WITH ANY OF THAT?
YOU KNOW YOU DIDN'T VERIFY IT,
THAT'S PREMEDITATED FRAUD UNDER
COURT.
THEN WHEN YOU KNOW THAT YOU LIED
TO THE COURT, SUPPOSED TO GO
BACK AND TELL THEM.
I JUST HAVE A FUNNY FEELING THAT
IF IT HAPPENS TO ANYONE IN HIS
AUDIENCE YOU WOULD HAVE A
PREDAWN RATE LIKE AMANDA FORD
AND ROGER STONE AND I'VE BEEN
SAYING THIS FOR A WHILE BUT WHAT
WE WITNESSED IN 2016 FROM OUR
GOVERNMENT, BIGGEST ABUSE OF
POWER, CORRUPTION, SCANDAL AND
OUR HISTORY.
THE TRUTH IS GOING TO COME OUT.
THE BIG QUESTION I HAVE TONIGHT,
WILL THEY HOLD THEIR OWN
ACCOUNTABLE?
I'VE SOURCES TELLING ME TONIGHT
THEY MIGHT BE AFRAID TO DO THAT.
WITH THE FULL REPORT ON ALL OF
THIS IS OUR VERY OWN
CATHERINE HERRIDGE TONIGHT.
>> GOOD EVENING.
SENIOR ADMINISTRATION OFFICIAL
CONFIRMS FOX NEWS THE
INVESTIGATION INTO THE GENESIS
OF THE TRANSITING FBI RUSSIA
COLLUSION CASE IS EXPANDING
BASED ON THE FINDINGS OF U.S.
ATTORNEY JOHN DUREN.
APPOINTED BY ATTORNEY GENERAL
WILLIAM BARR IN MAY, THE
INVESTIGATION NOW HAS GLOBAL
REACH WITH DURUM RECENTLY
TRAVELING TO BRITAIN AND ITALY
TO PURSUE SURVEILLANCE LEADS AS
WELL AS WORKING WITH AUSTRALIAN
AUTHORITIES.
THE INVESTIGATION ALSO ADDING
MORE AGENTS, MORE RESOURCES FOR
AN EXPANDED TIMELINE WHICH NOW
STRETCHES FROM THE SPRING OF
2016 TO MAY 2017 WHEN THE
PRESIDENT FIRED FBI DIRECTOR
JAMES COMEY AND THEN DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
APPOINTED SPECIAL COUNSEL
ROBERT MUELLER.
BASED ON MY TWO DECADES COVERING
INTELLIGENCE AND
LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE EXPANDED
DURHAM PROBE INDICATES HE FOUND
EVIDENCE THAT LIKELY POINTS TO
CRIMINAL WRONGDOING BY
REPUTATION.
HE IS NOT A PROSECUTOR TO ASK
FOR MORE HELP.
SEPARATELY IN ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS TELL FOX NEWS THERE IS
NEW SCRUTINY OF THE MUELLER
APPOINTMENT.
COORDINATION BETWEEN ROSENSTEIN
AND MUELLER IN THE DAYS BEFORE
THE ANNOUNCEMENT AS WELL AS
ALLEGATIONS ROSENSTEIN OFFERED
TO WEAR A WIRE AND SECRETLY
REQUIRE THE PRESIDENT WHICH HE
IS PUBLICLY DENYING.
MULTIPLE ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS TOLD FOX NEWS THAT
WHEN MUELLER WITH THE MET WITH
THE PRESIDENT ON MAY 2816,
INDEED PURSUING THE POST LEFT
OPEN BY THE FIRING OF CALL ME A
WEEK EARLIER AND THEY SAY NEWLY
RELEASED RECORDS BACK UP THE
WHITE HOUSE ACCOUNT.
DURING THE CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY ON THE RUSSIA PRO, HE
SAID HE WAS NOT APPLYING AS FBI
DIRECTOR.
HE WAS OFFERING INPUT ON THE
REQUIRED SKILLS.
>> Sean: CATHERINE HERRIDGE IN
WASHINGTON TONIGHT.
THANK YOU.
ALSO TONIGHT, WE AREN'T NO
LONGER GOING TO REFER TO THE
POLITICAL WITCH HUNT.
THE LATEST WITCH HUNT ON
CAPITOL HILL AS ANY REAL TYPE OF
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
IT IS JUST THE LATEST ATTEMPT AT
SKILL AS A DULY ELECTED
PRESIDENT BY WE THE PEOPLE.
OVER MISCONDUCT THAT DOES NOT
EXIST YET AGAIN.
LET US BE CLEAR.
THEY NEVER ACCEPTED THE 2016
ELECTION RESULTS, THEY NEVER
ACCEPT AND FORGO SEPARATE
INVESTIGATIONS.
NO RUSSIA COLLUSION.
THAT INSTEAD WAS A COUP ATTEMPT.
IT SO NOW THEY WANT FROM ONE
FISHING EXPEDITION TO ANOTHER
FISHING EXPEDITION.
RUSSIA RUSSIA RUSSIA.
THAT COUP ATTEMPTS.
THEN IT WAS A TAX RETURN COUP
ATTEMPTS AND IT WAS A STORMY
STORMY COUP ATTEMPT.
NOW IT'S AT THE UKRAINE COUP
ATTEMPT.
THAT'S ALL THIS IS.
THEY CANNOT ACCEPT THE WILL OF
THE PEOPLE.
INSANE OBSESSIVE-COMPULSIVE
PSYCHOTIC WITCH HUNTS ROOTED IN
RAGE AND LACK OF CONNECTION TO
REALITY THAT THEY LOST.
SAME GOAL, LET'S IMPEACH THEM
AND WE HAVE A LOT OF WAYS WE CAN
IMPEACH HIM NANCY PELOSI SAYS.
THEY HAVE BEEN PLOTTING
IMPEACHMENT OF THIS PRESIDENT
FROM THE VERY BEGINNING.
THE MOMENT HE WAS ELECTED.
WE WILL REMIND YOU.
>> IF HE TAKES THE LEAD AT THE
RISK AND HE IS CONVICTED I COULD
BE SEEN AS AN IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSE.
>> I DON'T SEE WHERE THAT WOULD
BE AN IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
>> AND OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY --
>> IMPEACHMENT WARRANT.
>> NEW ELEMENTS ON THE
IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY.
>> IMPEACHABLE.
>> WE ARE INTRODUCING ARTICLES
OF IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT.
>> THE I WORD, IMPEACHMENT.
>> THE I WORD IMPEACHMENT.
>> IMPEACHMENT.
>> Sean: THERE THEY ARE.
IT STARTED TWO DAYS AFTER THE
PRESIDENT'S ELECTION AND HIS
STORY THAT WE SEE OVER UKRAINE
IS JUST THE LATEST COUP ATTEMPT.
THE LATEST CHAPTER IN WHAT HAS
BEEN THREE LONG YEARS OF LIES,
CONSPIRACY THEORIES, TO TAKE
DOWN A PRESIDENT THAT THEY NEVER
WANTED ELECTED IN THE FIRST
PLACE AND DID EVERYTHING THEY
COULD DO TO PREVENT THEM FROM
WINNING.
ALSO BREAKING MOMENTS AGO,
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL HAS ISSUED A
LETTER TO HOUSE DEMOCRATS
FORMALLY ANNOUNCING THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT
COOPERATE WITH THE
UNCONSTITUTIONAL INVALID
BASELESS INQUIRY BECAUSE OF THE
RICO DISTINCT ISSUES.
FIRST, IT'S CONSTITUTIONALLY
INVALID.
VIOLATES SEPARATION OF POWERS.
THERE HAS NO VOTE OF AUTHORIZING
THIS WITCH HUNT INQUIRY AND THAT
MEANS NO DUE PROCESS.
NO ABILITY FOR THE PRESIDENT'S
LAWYERS TO CROSS-EXAMINE
WITNESSES.
KNOWABILITY OF THE LAWYER TO
CALL WITNESSES.
NO ABILITY TO ENTER EVIDENCE
INTO THE RECORD.
INSTEAD ALL WE GOT WAS A PRESS
CONFERENCE FROM GAS, SPEAKER AND
NAME ONLY, NANCY PELOSI AND
ICARLY SHIFTY ADAM SCHIFF.
THIS IS UNPRECEDENTED AND
UNCONSTITUTIONAL.
THE IMPEACHMENT INQUIRY PLAINLY
SEEKS TO REVERSE THE ELECTION OF
2016 AND TO INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION OF 2020 AND ACCORDING
TO THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL, THE
AN EFFORT TO IMPEACH TRUMP
WITHOUT REGARD TO ANY OF HIS
EFFORTS IN THE HOUSE PERHAPS
BEFORE.
I WOULD ARGUE BEFORE.
IMPEACHMENT IS NEVER TO BE USED
AS A POLITICAL WEAPON ONLY AS A
CHECK AGAINST TREASON, BRIBERY,
HIGH CRIMES, MISDEMEANORS.
THAT BRINGS US TO THE THIRD
ISSUE THAT IS RAISED BY THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL.
QUOTE, THERE IS NO LEGITIMATE
BASIS FOR YOUR IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
INSTEAD OF THE COMMITTEE'S
ACTIONS, THEY RAISE SERIOUS
CONCERNS.
THAT WOULD BE LIKE THE COWARDLY
ADAM SCHIFF MAKING UP SOMETHING
IN A TRANSCRIPT THAT DIDN'T
EXIST WHERE THEY ANNOUNCE THE
IMPEACHMENT HEARING WHERE WE
HAVE A VARIETY OF OPTIONS AND NO
QUID PRO QUO THERE.
DEMOCRATS CLEAN THE INQUIRY IS
ABOUT SO CALLED A WHISTLE-BLOWER
OR NONWHISTLE-BLOWER OR ACCOUNT
OF A PHONE CALL BETWEEN
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE.
WHILE THE INQUIRY WAS ANNOUNCED
BEFORE DEMOCRATS EVEN SAW THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE CALL OR DID
THEY?
CAN.
WHAT DID SCHIFF KNOW AND WHEN
DID HE KNOW IT?
HE NOW IS THE LEAD INVESTIGATOR
RUNNING THIS COMMITTEE PRETTY
WOULD BE A MATERIAL FACT WITNESS
IN THIS CASE WOULDN'T HE?
THAT WOULD THEN CAUSE HIM TO
HAVE TO RECUSE HIMSELF.
BY THE WAY, THAT WAS A PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATE CONVERSATION WITH
THE PRESIDENT.
WE HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
NO NEED FOR NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
AND THE GOVERNMENT VIA GRANTS OF
THE TALL WAS TOTALLY
APPROPRIATE.
THE U.S. TO PRIMITIVE JUSTICE OF
THE CALL WAS APPROPRIATE.
U.S. AMBASSADOR TO THE
EUROPEAN UNION SAID THE
PRESIDENT DID NOTHING WRONG.
THE SPECIAL ENVOY TO UKRAINE,
KURT VOLKER, TESTIFIED UNDER
OATH BEHIND CLOSED DOORS.
NO QUID PRO QUO.
NO MISCONDUCT.
NO NOTHING.
LET'S NOT FORGET THE TRANSCRIPT
HAS BEEN RELEASED AS EVERYBODY
TO SEE.
WE DON'T NEED A
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWERS ACCOUNT AND THEY
THEIR FEELINGS AND POLITICAL
EVENT ON ANY OF THIS.
HERE'S WHAT CONGRESSMAN
LEE ZELDIN HOW TO SAY ABOUT THIS
VERY ISSUE EARLIER TODAY.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> MAYBE YOU SHOULD ASK WHAT WAS
SAID INSIDE OF VOLKER'S
DEPOSITION.
DURING HIS TRANSCRIBED INTERVIEW
WITH REGARDS TO ADAM SCHIFF'S
VERY DETAILED QUID PRO QUO
CHARGE THAT AIDS FROM THE
UNITED STATES TO UKRAINE WAS
BEING LINKED TO AN INVESTIGATION
FROM THE BITE AND SPREAD WHY
DON'T YOU ASK WHAT HE SAID ABOUT
THAT?
THAT'S A GREAT QUESTION BUT I'M
GLAD YOU ASKED AND I WILL TELL
YOU THE REASON WHY THE QUESTION
WAS SO IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO ASK
IS FOR MANY THINGS BECAUSE HE
WAS IN THIS ROOM FOR SEVERAL
HOURS AND DURING SEVERAL HOURS
OF TESTIMONY, HE TALKED ABOUT
HOW PRESIDENT ZELENSKY HAD NO
IDEA THAT THERE WAS A HOLD ON
AID AT THE TIME OF THE JULY 25TH
CALL.
INVESTOR VOLKER JUST AVOID ABOUT
HOW THE READOUT OF THE CALL WAS
MADE TO HIM HOW THERE WAS
NOTHING TO READ OUT THERE BEING
A HOLD ON U.S. AID OR A PRINT
QUID PRO QUO.
BY THE WAY, HE TESTIFIED TO THIS
ENTIRE TIME THE AID GETTING
RELEASED.
IT WAS GOING TO GET RELEASED.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENS?
THE AID GOT RELEASED AND YOU
KNOW WHAT DIDN'T HAVE TO HAPPEN?
THERE WAS NO NEW INVESTIGATION
THAT HAD TO GET CREATIVE.
THIS WHOLE THING IS A
FAIRY TALE.
ADAM SCHIFF IS MISLEADING YOU
AND YOU ARE PLAYING ALONG WITH
IT.
WHAT ADAM SCHIFF SAID FOR
EXAMPLE THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ASKING PRESIDENT ZELINSKI TO
MANUFACTURE DIRT ON THE BIDENS.
PRESIDENT VOLKER TESTIFIED TO
THAT BEING ABSOLUTELY UNTRUE.
>> Sean: FOR WEEKS THE
COWARDLY LYING ADAM SCHIFF
WANTED YOU TO BELIEVE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP THREATEN TO
WITHHOLD U.S. AID TO UKRAINE IF
HE DIDN'T INVESTIGATE SLEEPY
CREEPY CRAZY UNCLE JOE AND HIS
SONS SHADY UKRAINIAN BUSINESS
DEALS AND FOR WEEKS THE MEDIA
MOB BREATHLESSLY REPORTING ABOUT
TRUMP UKRAINE QUID PRO QUO AND
YET AGAIN IT WAS A BIG GIANT
HOAX AND ANOTHER LIE AND ANOTHER
CONSPIRACY THEORY.
THREE LONG YEARS.
AT ONE WITCH HUNT AFTER ANOTHER.
ONE COUP ATTEMPT AFTER ANOTHER.
TONIGHT WE HAVE BRAND-NEW
EVIDENCE PROVING BEYOND ANY
SHADOW OF A DOUBT THAT THE LAST
HYSTERIA IS ONCE AGAIN BUILT ON
ANOTHER BOUT OF LIES.
INVESTIGATE WROTE REPORTER JOHN
SOLOMON IT HAS ACQUIRED
DOCUMENTATION SHOWING THAT A NEW
INVESTIGATION WAS OPENED BY THE
COUNTRY'S PROSECUTOR GENERAL FOR
MONTHS BEFORE THE PHONE CALL
WITH OUR PRESIDENT AND THE
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT ZELINSKI
UNDER UKRAINE'S PRIOR PRESIDENT
AND THAT'S NOT ALL.
JOHN SOLOMON REPORTING ALSO
TONIGHT ONE FOCAL POINT OF THE
INVESTIGATION WAS WHETHER ANY OF
THE $3.4 MILLION IN PROCEEDS
THAT BURIES MY HOLDINGS PAYING
THE BIDENS CAME FROM ILLICIT
SOURCES.
THIS HAPPENED MONTHS BEFORE THE
PHONE CALL IN QUESTION WHICH IS
BY THE WAY HUGE BUT EVEN MORE.
WE HAVE BRAND-NEW DETAILS ABOUT
THE NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
BYRON YORK REPORTING TONIGHT.
HERE SHE HAD A PROFESSIONAL TIED
TO A 2020
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE WHICH MEANS
THAT HE OR SHE WORKS WITH OR
FOR ONE OF THE DEMOCRATS THAT IS
RUNNING AGAINST TROMP.
THAT WOULD BE A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST ESPECIALLY WHEN THE
GIVING HEARSAY EVIDENCE IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
LET'S RECAP.
NONWHISTLE-BLOWER
WHISTLE-BLOWER.
REGISTERED DEMOCRAT.
CLEAR POLITICAL BIAS.
PROFESSIONAL RELATIONSHIP WITH
ONE OF THE 2020 DEMOCRATS WHO
WANT TO BE TROMP.
COMPLETE BASED ON HEARSAY NOT
FIRST-HAND KNOWLEDGE AND ALSO
MEDIA REPORTS.
DOESN'T EVEN MATTER WHAT THE
COMPLAINT CLAIMS BECAUSE AS WE
KNOW NOW TO THE TRANSCRIPT, WHAT
WAS SAID AND WHAT WASN'T SAID
DON'T WE?
BY THE WAY, THE CALL IN QUESTION
SHOWS NO QUID PRO QUO.
NOTHING.
NO FUNDS WERE WITHHELD FROM
UKRAINE.
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS DIDN'T EVEN
KNOW THE PRESIDENT WAS
CONSIDERING DELAYING AID AT THE
TIME OF THE CALL.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE THE COWARDLY
ADAM SCHIFF, KNOWN CONGENITAL
LIAR, THEN YOU HAVE NANCY PELOSI
COME ANOTHER LIAR WHO LOST ALL
CONTROL OVER HER PARTY IN THE
HOUSE.
THEY WANT TO BOOT AND DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT FROM OFFICE
FOR NOTHING.
WHAT?
A COUP AND AN ATTEMPT THAT EVERY
DEMOCRAT MUST GO ON RECORD
ABOUT.
ANY SO-CALLED, BY THE WAY, THESE
SO-CALLED MODERATES, IN OTHER
WORDS, THE DEMOCRATS THAT LIVE
IN DISTRICTS THAT DONALD TRUMP
WON IN 2016, THEY DON'T SPEAK
OUT AGAINST THIS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL ATTEMPTED COUP
AND WITCH HUNT.
THEY WOULD BE COMPLICIT IN WHAT
IS AN ILLEGAL ATTEMPT TO
OVERRIDE THE WILL OF THE
AMERICAN VOTER.
NOW THERE IS REAL CORRUPTION AND
GOVERNMENT ABUSE OF POWER AND A
QUID PRO QUO WE ACTUALLY HAVE ON
TAPE.
THAT WOULD BE JOE BIDEN AND THE
COUNTRY OF UKRAINE BECAUSE AS
THE MEDIA MOB TRIES TO IGNORE
THAT BREWING SCANDAL,
SENATOR LINDSEY GRAHAM IS NOW
INVITING THE YOU NEW YORK
SENATOR RUDY GIULIANI TO TESTIFY
BEFORE CONGRESS ABOUT HIS
LENGTHY INVESTIGATION.
DON'T FORGET, LEARN FROM
POLITICO.
WHAT DO WE LEARN?
UKRAINE WAS HELPING HILLARY AND
THEY WERE INVOLVED IN THE
INTERFERENCE OF THE ELECTION OF
2016.
AND JOE SHUT DOWN UKRAINE IS
THAT YOU HAVE SIX HOURS AND
YOU FIRE THAT PROSECUTOR OR I'M
TAKING MY BILLION DOLLARS, OUR
BILLION DOLLARS, THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE'S BILLION DOLLARS, AND